monsieur le ministre vous avez à
plusieurs reprises
regrettées on peut le comprendre ce que
beaucoup maintenant appellent désormais
grâce à Donald Trump les fake news et
vous avez raison mais vous avez depuis
le début de ce cette séquence vous-même
contribuez à cette situation et donc je
voulais savoir comment vous envisagiez
la suite de vos déclarations vous avez
dit le 21 mars et vous l'avez répété le
28 mars être dans une manifestation non
déclarée est un délit nous savons tout
ce qu'il n'en est rien et cela a été
rappelé y compris par le Conseil d'État
vous avez indiqué le 27 mars concernant
la brave m que cette la section de la
brave m qui avait été mise en cause dans
les événements sur lequel peut revenir
mais je n'ai pas le temps dans les deux
minutes
avait été écarté tout en disant dans une
ce qu'on pourrait qualifier d'oxymore
ils n'ont pas été identifiés
formellement mais il m'a été confirmé
qui ne serait pas engagé dans la
manifestation de mardi ce qui était
quand même un tour de force et enfin
vous avez indiqué ainsi que votre préfet
de police que il y avait ce qu'on
pourrait appeler un signalement
automatique des violences filmées et
quand on se renseigne auprès de la
préfecture il s'avère qu'il n'y a aucun
service sur ce point et que de fait
malgré l'activité sur les réseaux
sociaux il n'y a pas de dispositif dédié
qui permettent d'identifier les dérives
des forces de l'ordre donc je vous
interroge pour savoir comment vous
entendez y répondre et puis je vous ai
posé une question d'actualité mercredi
dernier à laquelle sur un point vous
n'avez pas répondu donc je suis
quelqu'un de obstiné
vous avez vous avez fait la une du JDD
je vous en félicite sans doute en
indiquant que vous refusiez de céder au
terrorisme intellectuel de l'extrême
gauche ether ben Bassa a parfaitement
rappelé je suis élu de Paris le terme de
terrorisme pour français d'ailleurs et
quelque chose que vous ne devriez pas
utiliser de manière un peu rapide mais
je vous demandais lors des dernières
questions d'actualité si vous étiez prêt
à adresser aux membres des forces de
l'ordre la lettre que le préfet Grimaud
avait envoyé le 29 mai 68 à l'ensemble
des de ces agents qui disaient je dis la
phrase la plus marquante frappée un
manifestant tomber à terre c'est se
frapper soi-même en apparaissant sous un
jour qui atteint toute la fonction
policière vous ne m'avez pas répondu je
ne pense pas que vous considérez que le
préfet Grimaud pratiqué le terrorisme
intellectuel je rappelle qu'à la
préfecture de police de Paris une salle
d'ailleurs a été dénommée en honneur du
préfet
alors je vais de la parole au ministre
pour cette première partie de réponse et
puis nous redébuterons dès que
l'intention s'est terminée par Monsieur
bonne Carrère
bien merci beaucoup j'ai peut-être
commencé par répondre à madame la
sénatrice
quelle est le Conseil d'État sur la
manifestation c'est que j'ai dit une
incision mais ce n'était pas faux je
rappelle madame satrice vous faites la
loi que une manifestation
interdite
qui n'est pas déclaré prévu depuis le
décalois de 1935 et désormais l'article
elle 211 est suivant fait que si on
organise manifestation non déclaré ou
interdite cela constitue en effet un
délit 431,9 du code pénal 6 mois
d'emprisonnement participer si vous me
laissez terminer vous allez voir je suis
sûr que vous verrez une cohérence ça va
penser en tout cas je l'espère donc
d'abord organiser mes faisceaux
interdits c'est un délit participer à
une manifestation interdite c'est une
infraction punie de la contravention de
quatrième classe et constituée un
rassemblement de personnes sur la
République dans un lieu public se situe
de trouver l'ordre public notamment
lorsque la manifestation est interdite
431 3 c'est aussi un délit donc je
peut-être évoquer le fait que vous
n'encouragez pas à manifester alors
j'aimerais que vous puissiez m'écouter
madame la satrice j'aimerais que vous
puissiez m'écouter sans le ministre
est-ce que en effet si vous ne m'écoutez
pas vous risquez pas de m'entendre même
si vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec moi
ensuite pardon mais tout ce que vous
avez dit Madame la madame la Première
ministre ce que je me plaise madame la
sénatrice il faut permettez-moi juste de
corriger votre propos sans doute en
début de langage sur votre préfet de
police j'ai senti à la fois du mépris et
une insulte pour le préfet de police
peut-être le préfet de police de la
République ce serait une bonne chose je
je pense que ce serait une bonne chose
de respecter les fonctionnaires qui sont
pas là et qui ne sont pas là pour vous
répondre donc le préfet de police la
bravem oui les 5 individus qui sont
soupçonnés d'avoir été dans
l'enregistrement audio que nous avons
entendu et qui était évidemment
scandaleux n'ont pas été sur la voie
publique parmi ces cinq nous ne savons
pas encore exactement qui des deux
personnes ont parlé donc tout à fait ils
n'ont pas été sur la publicité ah oui
c'est ça qui n'ont pas été totalement
identifiés une enquête administrative
deuxièmement vous et c'est très
intéressant que j'ai pas le droit
d'utiliser le mot le mot terrorisme mais
vous n'êtes pas la police des mots
madame de La Gontrie c'est justement ça
une partie de ce que c'est de faire la
police de la pensée le camp du Bien
comme dirait Philippe muret fait partie
manifestement du camp du Bien et vous
vous considérez qu'il y a des gens qui
peuvent utiliser des mots et d'autres
qui ne peuvent pas le faire il n'y a pas
de police des mots démocratie madame la
sénatrice et vous n'avez pas l'apanage
ni de la morale et du vocabulaire je
mets des mots sur les choses jeter des
cocktails Motors sur des gendarmes c'est
de la terreur parce que vous n'avez
jamais été parmi les jardins pour
recevoir des cocktails Molotov parmi eux
moi je vous encourage demain matin
plutôt que d'évoquer l'honneur de la
police gendarmerie jetez parfois au
chien comme on aurait dit un ancien
président de la République passer une
journée avec la brave pour voir ce qu'il
toute la journée ils ont comme violence
en face de une jurisolive je peux la
demander il est allé il est revenu je
crois impressionner
BFM l'a demandé pour ses confuserait je
pense que tous les Français ont vu ce
que c'était alors pose de télévision
d'ailleurs le journaliste a été blessé
n'hésitez pas moi ouvrage demain je vous
donne rendez-vous si vous le souhaitez
évidemment c'est total liberté vous
venez à 8 heures du matin 7h du matin on
prend toute la journée parmi les
manifestations n'hésitez pas n'hésitez
pas à venir malheureusement je constate
que c'est plus facile de le faire de
loin que de le faire de près auprès
d'eux c'est dommage parce que comme la
très bien dit moi je vous encourage vous
avez lu le JDD c'est vous avez des
bonnes lectures le dimanche
manifestement mais je vous encourage à
écouter Bernard Cazal ce matin sur
France Inter je passe écouter ce matin
sur France Inter mais c'était je crois
extrêmement intéressant et ça permettait
de constater en effet qu'il y avait sur
notre dans notre République évidemment
et bien évidemment une gauche qui
soutient les forces de l'ordre n'est pas
oui mais pour les forces de l'ordre je
te donnerai par dire madame je
reviendrai pour vous monsieur le
sénateur je voudrais pas dire pour vous
comparez mes 68 vous savez qu'il y a eu
7 morts mais 68 madame la sénatrice vous
savez qu'il y a eu 2000 blessés dont
plus de 400 très gravement entre 200 et
400 très gravement vous comparez
l'incomparable et c'est ça une forme
aussi c'est ça aussi une forme de police
vous comparez des choses qui n'ont rien
à voir Madame madame la sénatrice voilà
donc je crois que un peu un peu de un
peu de modération pour les propos et de
soutien aux forces de l'ordre je pense
que certains la personne ce sont des
gens vous savez qu'une partie d'entre
eux qui vous ont abandonné
électoralement il faut vous demander
pourquoi peut-être parce que vous ne
défendez pas au moment où ils sont
attaqués et que vous mettez un signe
égal madame la sénatrice entre la police
la gendarmerie et les castors il y a pas
de Sénégal parce que oui mais tu as un
signe égal intellectuellement il n'y a
pas de signe il y a pas de il y a pas de
vous dites les violences de qui viennent
des enfants qui viennent des blessés de
qui viennent il n'y a pas de Sénégal
parce qu'il y en a qui ont la force il y
en a qui il y en a qui ont la force du
droit et de la loi que vous élaborez et
il y en a qui n'ont pas la force du
droit et de la loi et qu'utilise la
violence tout court et c'est extrêmement
différent et je pense qu'il faut
rappeler les choses et je je je
suis personnellement très touché quand
je vois des policiers des gendarmes qui
se sentent par des discours politiques
comme les vôtres insultés voilà moi
c'est ce que je vous dis très très
proche
[Musique]